by 2023 66 percent of people on the
planet will be connected to the internet
data scientists are the next perfect
profession because they can expect to
make between sixty five thousand dollars
and one fifty three thousand dollars
annually the field of data science is a
hot cake and has a promising future hey
everyone before moving on to today's
topic please make sure you subscribe to
our channel and press the bell icon to
never miss an update let us check out
today's agenda
starting with what is data science next
difference between tools and libraries
further we will cover top 10 data
science tools following it top 10 data
science libraries and final is
conclusion to the topic
before accelerating forward let me ask
you a question
which is the famous programming language
used in data science
java
c hash
c plus plus r
let me know the answer in the comment
section below
first let's understand what is data
science data science is a field of study
that works with enormous amount of data
utilizing contemporary technologies and
methodologies to uncover hidden patterns
obtain valuable information and make
business decisions in a simpler way data
science is the field of extracting
valuable information from data using
scientific methods which will help in
decision making for businesses
data scientists should be aware of the
field of machine learning
modeling like mathematical models and
algorithms statistics programming and
databases
now we know what data science is we will
understand the difference between tools
and libraries
tools are any software programs or
utilities that help software developers
or programmers create modify debug
maintain or carry out any tasks
relevant to programming or development
is referred to as a programming tool
software development tools are another
name for programming tools
libraries in computer programming
library is a group of documents
applications scripts routines or
functions that can be used as references
in the source code
we now know the difference between tools
and libraries it's time to jump for top
10 data science tools
first one is sas it stands for
statistical analysis system it belongs
to the class of data science tools made
especially for statistical processes
large corporations utilize sas a closed
source proprietary program to utilize
data sas does statistical modeling using
the fundamental size computer language
it is commonly used by experts
and business developing reputable
commercial software you can model and
organize your data using a variety of
statistical libraries and tools from sas
as a data scientist
let's look into features first is data
analysis skill
the first feature is that sas
programming is capable of performing
strong data analysis
flexibility syntax is easy to learn
statements are similar to the code these
sentences provide clear simple
instructions for the systems
next comes sas studio
studio is unique among sas features any
web browsers and any device can readily
access it there is no installation
needed on the client side
sas management sas management is one of
the important features of sas the sas
environment manager oversees the
analytics environment and issues alerts
next important tool is
apache spark
spark sometimes known as apache spark or
simply spark is the most popular data
science tool and an all powerful
analytics engine spark was created
primarily to perform batch and stream
processing it includes numerous apis
that makes it easy for data scientists
to repeatedly access data for machine
learning sql storage etc in comparison
to map reduce it can operate 100 times
quicker it is an upgrade over hadoop
features of apache spark
first is speed
large amount of complicated data must be
processed as a part of big data
processing therefore when it comes to
processing businesses and organizations
need such frameworks that can handle
enormous volumes of data quickly
next comes easy to use java scala python
and our programmers we create scalable
apps with spark as a result developers
can write and operate spark applications
using their choice programming language
flexibility
in addition to running on hadoop yan
apache
kubernetes and even in the cloud spark
may operate independently in cluster
mode also
sophisticated analysis in addition to
straightforward map and reduce
operations sql queries streaming data
and complex analysis such as machine
learning and graph algorithms are all
supported by spark
third one is big machine learning it is
another popular data science tool for
processing machine learning algorithms
it offers a fully interactive
cloud-based dui environment for industry
requirements big ml offers standardized
applications utilizing cloud computing
through it businesses can use machine
learning algorithms throughout their
entire organization picamel has a
specially in productive modeling it
employs a wide range of machine learning
algorithms including clustering
classification forecasting of time
series etc
coming to features
collaboration all employees in the firm
from analysis and developers to
engineers and executives can work
together transparently and openly on big
ml
automation utilize efficient automation
to quickly put your productive modeling
jobs into production big gamer
transforms time consuming tasks like
manually entering models or carrying out
intricate workflows into one click menu
selections or solitary api calls
next comes security and privacy every
user on big ml has a private dashboard
and any materials produced there or
through the big ml api are safe and
private all connections to big ml are
encrypted via https
matlab for processing mathematical data
matlab is a multi-parading numerical
computing environment matrix functions
algorithmic implementations and
statistical data modeling are made
easier by this closed source program the
majority of scientific areas make use of
matlab matlab is used in data science to
stimulate fuzzy logic and neural
networks the matlab graphics library
allows you to build robust
visualizations signal and image
processing also use matlab
features includes interactive
environment the interactive setting
offered by matlab enables iterative
exploration design and problem solving
it is a collection of resources that
programmers can utilize it features
tools for managing workspace variables
and importing and exporting data
additionally it includes tools for
processing debugging and profiling
matlab files
high level language in matlab
object-oriented programming is supported
additionally it supports other
programming constructs including control
flow statements like if else for while
etc additionally
allows structure similar to those seen
in c and functional programming
interactive graphics inbuilt visuals in
matlab improve the user experience any
data that is available can actually be
visualized using charts and figures
api that is application programming
interface and extensive api may be found
in matlab we may connect to our c or c
plus plus programmers directly through
matlab using this api
next comes tableau tableau is a data
visualization program with strong
visuals that can be used to create
interactive visualizations it is
concentrated on businesses involved in
business intelligence the ability of
tableau to connect to databases
spreadsheets
cubes and other system is its most
crucial features tableau also provides
the ability to visualize geographic data
and plot longitudes and latitudes on
maps in addition to these capabilities
features includes tableau dashboard
through the use of visualization visual
elements text etc tableau dashboard
provides you with a complete picture of
your data
security data and user security are
given great consideration by tableau it
has a robust security system based on
authentication and access control
mechanisms for users data and
communications
sharing and collaboration tableau offers
simple ways for users to work together
and rapidly share data in the form of
visualizations sheets dashboards etc
data source tableau enables you to
connect to a range of data source and
retrieve data from them local files
spreadsheets relational and
non-relational databases data warehouses
big data and on cloud data are just a
few of the many data sources that
tableau can access
next comes jupiter project jupiter is an
open source application built on
ipython that adds developers in creating
interactive computing experiences and
open source software multiple languages
including python and r are supported by
jupiter including java it is a web-based
tool for creating
presentations infographics and live code
a very well liked tool created to meet
the needs of data science is jupiter
data scientists can carry out all their
duties within the interactive
environment features include data
visualization you can create
visualizations with jupiter notebook
share them with others and make
interactive changes to the shared code
and data collection
next comes code sharing you can see code
in a jupiter notebook run it and see the
results in your web browser
interaction with code
the code in jupiter notebook is dynamic
it may be changed and executed gradually
in real time while receiving feedback
right in the browser
next comes ggplot2 advanced data
visualization software for the r
programming language is called ggplot2
this program was developed to take the
place of our default graphics packet
features includes data visualization the
most widely used data visualization
package in the r community is gg plot2 a
broad visualization framework that
divides graphs into semantic elements
like scales and layers
next comes geometry
it determines the type of plot such as
bar line or histogram
last feature is data
next comes scikit learn machine learning
algorithms are implemented using the
python module in scikit-learn it is a
tool that is frequently used for
analysis
it supports several machine learning
features including data pre-processing
classification regression clustering
dimensionally reduction etc the usage of
sophisticated machine learning methods
is made simply by scikit learn
features includes
data sets scikit learn includes a number
of built-in data sets including the iris
data set data sets on home prices data
sets on diabetes etc
data division the ability to divide the
data set into training and testing
sets was made available by scikit learn
linear regression when the output
variables is continuous and has a linear
relationship with the dependent
variables the supervised machine
learning
model is applied
it possesses features of supervising and
unsupervised learning in supervised
algorithms almost all well-known
supervised algorithms including linear
regression svm that is support vector
machine decision tree and others are
including inside kit learn and for
unsupervised algorithms it also includes
all of the well-known unsupervised
learning methods i repeat learning
methods including clustering factor
analysis
etc
next comes
important tool that is tensorflow a
common machine learning tool is now
tensorflow for complex machine learning
algorithms like deep learning it is
frequently employed
features includes scalability this open
source toolkit enables quick and simple
computations for machine learning it
makes it simpler to move algorithms from
one tensor flow tool to another
easy to run tensorflow apps can be run
on a variety of platforms including
android cloud and ios
speedy debugging it gives you the
ability to evaluate each node or action
separately
flexibility with the use of keras api
and data input pipelines tensorflow
offers the best method of solving
difficult topologies
and the last important tool is excel
probably the most used tool for data
analysis today excel is widely used for
data processing visualization and
complex calculations excel was created
by microsoft primarily for spreadsheet
computations excel is an effective data
science analysis tool excel is still a
powerful tool for data analysis despite
being the standard
features include titles and table
the x label and via label methods can be
used to add access labels the title
technique enables the addition of the
title
data visualization charts are more
useful than a sheet since they are easy
to create and can display data in a
variety of ways
excel offers best editors the tables are
simple to distribute format update and
colorize
this is all about top 10 data science
tool now we will see top libraries in
data science
is numpy
the essential python module for
numerical calculation is called numpy
and it includes potent n-dimensional
array object it is a general purpose
array processing software that offers
capabilities for working with high
performance multi-dimensional objects
known as array by offering
these multi-dimensional arrays as well
as functions and operators that works
effectively on these arrays numpy
partially overcomes the slowness issue
next is scipy
because it extends numpy and offers a
variety of user friendly and effective
routines for scientific calculations it
is widely used for scientific and
technical calculations a scientific
computation package called scipy is
built on top of numpy
python is a common abbreviation it
offers more helpful functions for signal
processing statistics and optimization
scipy is a open source therefore it can
be used just like numpy
the data science life cycle is not
complete without pandas along with numpy
in matte polyp it is the most well known
and commonly used python module for data
search
it is widely used for data analysis and
cleansing with almost 1700 comments on
github and has an active community of
1200 contributors
keras keras is another well-liked
framework that is frequently used for
deep learning and neural network models
much like tensorflow
if you don't want to get or into the
specific of tensorflow kera supports
both the theano and tensorflow packets
next comes pytorch the next best python
libraries for data science is pythons a
scientific computing toolkit built on
python that makes advantage of graphics
processing units
one of the most popular deep learning
research platforms
is pytorch which was designed to offer
greatest flexibility and speed
scrappy scrappy is the following
well-known python library for data
science one of the best well-liked quick
open source python web crawling
frameworks is called scrapping
using selector based on xpath it is
frequently used to extract data from web
pages scrappy creates feed exports like
xml csv json formats
next is beautiful soup the upcoming
python library for data science is
called beautiful su it is a well-liked
python package that is mostly used for
data scraping and web crawling users can
gather data from websites that don't
have adequate csv or apis and beautiful
so can assess them with scrapping the
data and organizing in the necessary
format
next comes plotly
data visualizations can be created using
plotly a graphing toolkit that is open
source and free in order to build
web-based data visualizations plotly is
built on top of javascript library
more than 40 different chart types
including multiple access
three-dimensional charts etc are
available in plotly
next comes seaborn based on matpo lip
and strongly connected with the numpy
and pandas data structures cbone is a
python data visualization framework
there are several data set oriented
graphing routines in seaborn that works
with data frames and arrays that contain
entire data set
the relevant statistical aggregations
and mapping operations are then carried
out internally to produce the user
requested informative displays
last is scikit learn
scikit learn is also a library that is
free machine learning software
library that is mostly written in python
computer language it was first
introduced in june 2007 after being
created by david as a google summer code
project due to its foundation on other
python libraries like numpy scipy
madpolet pandas etc scikit-learn offers
complete interchange with them although
scikit-learn is mostly built on python
some fundamental algorithm have also
been developed in cyto to increase
efficiency
have you guys got the answer for the
question we went through earlier
so answer to that question is our
programming language
this is all about top 10 libraries in
data science next is conclusion to the
topic
data is essential to any organization
survival in the competitive world of
today's data-driven society data
scientists use data to give important
insights to the main decision makers in
organizations without the use of the
potent data source techniques outlined
above this is almost unimaginable
it offers a method for performing data
analysis developing aesthetically
pleasing interactive visualizations and
creating robust predictive models using
machine learning algorithms these
capabilities make
data science simpler to extract and
deliver insightful information from
seemingly useless and raw data
after watching this video entirely you
may have realized that one of the most
notable characteristics of all this tool
is that they offer a user-friendly
interactive with built-in functions for
conducting computing on data increasing
efficiency and lowering the amount of
code required to extract value from the
provided data sourcing for meeting the
needs of end users as a result deciding
which tool to utilize from a variety
should be based on the particular need
for each use case
thank you for watching the video have a
great day happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here